Okay, folks.
Time to get started. Let's uh
Reminder again that next week is spring
break.
But the week you come back, that Friday
is when your evaluation is due. So, if
you haven't really done anything and you
want to go away in spring break, try to
get something done this week.
The second is that once you come back a
week from that Monday when you come back
is your second quiz.
It's later than it usually is in this
class for a simple reason, which is the
spring break this week is actually 1
week later than it usually is.
This semester, it's after your 17th
session instead of your 15th session.
So, your second and third quizzes are
going to be bunched up. What I'm trying
to say is when you when you come back,
the [__] is going to hit the fan. Right?
You're going to have the value the
project due, the quizzes coming. So, try
to get something productive done this
week.
No, and um I unless you want to take it
on your break with you.
So, today we're going to continue our
discussion of valuations.
So, let me start with a few questions
which we're going to run into today.
When you value a company, you often
worry about corporate governance.
Poor corporate governance. I want you to
start thinking already in your mind,
what does that mean? Poor corporate
governance.
Let's say you take a company that's
badly managed and badly run. You've
estimated a DCF value of 100 million for
the company.
And this company has bad corporate
governance.
Should you discount the value of this
company for the corporate governance?
I've got two hands up. What do you
think?
Yeah, you did the DCF, right? When you
did did the DCF, did you bring in the
bad cash flows in? Let's say the company
has good corporate governance. How would
I reflect that in the value? Sum it up.
Sorry?
In other words, revalue the company. So,
don't take existing value. So, take
existing valuation, leave it as a status
quo, then revalue the company with
better management in place. It could be
higher cash flows, less growth or more
growth. We'll come back and talk about
it. Maybe change your financing mix and
you'll get a value that's higher, right?
So, I've two values now for the company.
Which one do I use?
It does matter, right? Because which one
will
will will occur will depend on who's
running the company. So, good corporate
governance doesn't mean there's a
guarantee
that management will change. It's a you
improve the odds.
So, let's say there's now 60% chance of
management change because you've good
corporate governance, you would take an
expected value.
You're going to see me play this little
trick anytime I run into a question of,
hey, there can be two values for the
company depending on what happens.
Rather than try to bring them all into
one value, do two valuations, take an
expected value.
So, let's say you're doing a DCF value
of a company. You come up with a value
per share of $20. And to do the DCF
value, you stayed with the conventional
accounting numbers, operating income,
CapEx, working capital.
And remember we talked about R&D
changing all those numbers?
Let's say you go through and you say,
hey, I'm going to use the R&D corrected
numbers.
When you capitalize R&D
and you put that those corrected numbers
in, will your value per share go up and
down? I'll give you the choices. It
should remain unchanged. Money spent is
money spent.
You think that's the answer?
If that were the answer, would we ever
capitalize R&D?
You're going to get the same value. Who
cares, right? You So, clearly that can't
be the answer.
Will it make your value go up because
you now have higher earnings numbers?
They can see the good side, right?
Earnings are up. What's the bad side?
Reinvestment is also up.
Could the net effect be positive? Yes.
Could be negative. You know what's going
to drive it?
When you capitalize R&D, what are you
doing to it? You're treating it like any
other project, right?
Any other investment. When does an
investment add value? When it earns a
return that exceeds its cost of capital.
Companies that do good R&D will see
their value go up. Companies that do
substandard R&D will see the values go
down. I'm going to show you a valuation
of Amgen where I'm going to turn that
switch off for now. I'm going to look at
the value with traditional accounting
numbers, then I'm going to capitalize
R&D. And you're going to see the value
jump.
Then I'm going to take Merck and I'm
going to do exactly the same thing. And
Merck is a company that in the last 15
years has spent literally hundreds of
billions of dollars in R&D and has very
little to show for it.
So, there when I capitalize R&D, the
value will go down. The reason we
capitalize R&D is to separate the Mercks
from the Amgens of the world cuz you
want to reward companies that do good
R&D.
Finally.
Let's say you have a distressed company.
Ignore the title. You have a distressed
company with negative earnings.
You sit down to value the company. So,
what do you need to do on your
spreadsheet to make this company a
value?
Your negative earnings have to become
positive earnings. How? You put a target
margin. Your high debt ratio has become
a low debt ratio. Let's say you fix them
all on the spreadsheet. You come up with
a value per share.
Right? And the value you come up with is
a billion for the equity. On your
spreadsheet, we have fixed all the
problems.
Is that the right value for the company
or is it too low a value or too high a
value? What might I be missing when I do
a discounted cash flow valuation of a
distressed company and I fix all the
problems on my spreadsheet?
Do all distressed companies go back to
health?
What happens to many distressed
companies?
They crash, they burn, they fail, yeah?
You know what? In a discounted cash flow
valuation, it's very, very difficult to
bring failure into your D or your CF.
You're saying, why can't I raise my
discount rate? Blunt instrument was not
designed for that kind of risk.
So, you're saying, what do we do then? A
discounted cash flow valuation of a
distressed company is going to to give
too high a number. What did I do with
corporate governance? I valued the
company again where I said, what is the
likelihood that my company will not make
it, in which case will your equity be
worth a lot less, sometimes zero, then
take an expected value. Anytime you have
a discrete risk, nationalization risk,
distress risk, corporate governance
changes, it's better to do two
valuations and take an expected value.
And I want to open the door
to that discussion.
Okay, so we're going to go back to the
valuation. I'm going to start today by
valuing the market. I don't know whether
any of you
read the post I put up because that
includes a Tesla valuation. That Tesla
valuation is actually going to be the
valuation of the week for this week.
Because if you want to see a comp story
play out in a valuation, there is no
better company
to see both good turns and bad turns in
stories.
So, here's what I'm going to do. I'm
going to take you back 3M. I remember
the valuation. I'm going to take what I
did for Con Ed and 3M and extend it to
the entire market. Can I do an intrinsic
valuation of the market? If you
remember, this was your first valuation
of the week. Go back and take a look at
it cuz I valued the company at the start
of 2025.
But I'm going to take you through the
process of how I think about valuing an
entire market.
This was in September of 2022.
September of 2022, inflation had made a
comeback, stocks were being hammered.
And there was talk that the market was
overvalued. So, I said, look, I want to
value the entire S&P 500 to make a
judgment on whether the market is
overvalued.
So, what you see there is a structure to
get my value for the for an entire
index, and still the structure that I
use, I'm first going to project out the
expected earnings on the index. For how
long? For only 5 years.
Why? Cuz these are the 500 largest
market cap stocks in the market. They're
not going to grow at a rate higher than
the economy for very long. So, after 5
years, I assume that the growth will
drop to the growth rate of the economy,
which I
estimate using a risk-free rate. So, my
earnings So, you're saying, where are
you going to get earnings for the S&P
500 for the next 5 years?
The S&P is the most widely tracked and
followed index in the world. There are
analysts whose only job it is to
estimate what the earnings will be for
the index. I'm going to take their
analyst estimates of earnings and put
them in. Could they be wrong?
Absolutely.
We'll talk about which direction they're
wrong in, how that might have to be
factored in. So, I take the expected
earnings on the index.
But I don't collect earnings, right? I
get cash flows.
Now, if these are 500 companies, I don't
want to be computing free cash flow of
the firm for every company, not to
mention the fact that if the financial
services companies I'm going to get
stuck. So, I cheat. The way I estimate
the free cash flow of the firm for the
entire index is I look at the aggregate
dividends and stock buybacks from all of
the companies in the index.
And that's public information, right?
You can get it from S&P, you can get it
from the financial statements.
So, I take the earnings and project them
out, estimate the cash flows as a
percentage of those earnings.
And then discount them back
at what?
The cost of equity. Why cost of equity?
I looked at dividends and buybacks. I
could have valued the index using firm
valuation, but then I would subtract out
the debt, so I stay with cash flows to
equity. I use a
And what goes into cost of equity for a
company? Risk-free rate, beta, equity
risk premium, right?
But in the index, the beta drops out.
Why? Cuz it's the index, beta's going to
be roughly equal to one. I do an equal
risk-free rate and an equity risk
premium.
You discount the cash flows back at that
cost of equity. What do you get as a
present value is the intrinsic value of
the index.
So, I'm going to take you through what I
did in September of 2022 and talk a
little bit about what those numbers look
like at the start of 2025.
So, what's my first step? I want to look
at what analysts were projecting as
earnings. And in doing all of this there
were there were big questions I was
unsure about that hung over my
valuation. The first is there was talk
of a recession. Remember for a long
period people were saying the
recession's coming, there's a talk of a
recession. And my first question is are
analysts reflecting that in their
earnings numbers?
Second stop, to estimate cash flows I
can look at dividends and buybacks that
companies are paying, and in the 12
months leading into September of 2022,
US companies had returned about 90% of
their earnings in the form of dividends
and buybacks. And they've been doing
this for a long time.
So, what drives how much cash companies
collectively return?
One is confidence, right?
Second is share, but these are 500 all
500 companies. Unless there's collective
pressure, it's a you know, it can't With
individual companies, you can talk about
shareholders' pressure, but this is this
the aggregate.
I talked about confidence. Why does
confidence matter? If you feel confident
about earnings, you're more likely to
pay cash flows.
The market is doing well, you feel that
you can go back and raise capital in
case you needed it. So, those things all
feed in. File that away, because if
inflation is changing that dynamic, that
90% might become lower. So, I've got to
leave open that question.
Third, I was, you know, there was no way
around the fact that inflation was the
star in the show now. I had to figure
out what that inflation number would
look like 5 years out. And September
2022, inflation had climbed to 6 or 7%,
but nobody was sure about whether it was
going to go to 10% or back to 2%. So,
those were open.
And finally, those inflation numbers
would feed out both in my risk-free
rate, because higher inflation push up
my T-bond rate, and also make my equity
risk premium higher. Lots of unanswered
questions. I wanted to think about what
the unanswered questions would be today
if you're valuing the index.
And it's no surprise, you open up the
Wall Street Journal, you see the
headlines, right?
We'll talk about those questions, but
those were the questions I had in
September of 2022. So, let me lead in. I
started by looking at what analysts were
projecting as earnings for the index
every Since I do this at the start of
every month, I was able to track those
numbers. What was I looking at? I was
looking to see if analysts were lowering
their estimates of earnings for the
index as you went through the year as
the talk of recession picked up.
I couldn't see any change. It looked
like analysts were not as worried about
a recession as economists were. In
hindsight,
who was right?
The analysts were right. There was no
recession, so I'm not going to pick on
them. They were saying, "No." But at
that time, it looked unrealistic that
they were not bringing it in.
As for the cash return, I told you this
is a statistic that's gone all over.
This is going back to 2001. I've looked
at the percentage of earnings that
companies have returned in the form of
dividends and buybacks.
In 2001, they returned 77%, but you can
see over time they've gone The number's
gone up and down. The average over that
entire period was about 85%
of earnings. The median is about 83%.
They're at 90%. They're pushing towards
the top limits of that number.
So, I'm ready to actually value the
index.
This is my valuation of the index. It
will reflect my views, and you can say,
"Well, I would have done it
differently." That's why these indices
are open for different judge
So, I start with the earnings.
And in 2022, I said analysts are being
unrealistic. I'm going to lower the
earnings number they're giving me by
15%. I built in a drop in earnings. So,
I'm being a little more pessimistic than
the market.
Second,
companies were returning 90% of their
earnings as cash. I assumed it would
drop to 80%. Why? Inflation was making
things more uncertain. They wouldn't
feel as comfortable.
Third, I did assume that inflation had
topped out. That the 4% T-bond rate you
were seeing was now a steady state. It
wasn't going to 8 or 10%. So, embedded
in this valuation is the assumption that
inflation wouldn't become
hyperinflation.
And for the equity risk premium, I used
a 5% risk premium, roughly the average
between 2008 and 2022.
So, you put in the cash flow the
earnings, the cash flows,
and after your five Assume the cash
flows continue forever. What I got as a
value for the index is 3,516.
The index was at at about 3,600. You're
within 4% of the index. That's within
sneezing distance of the index. I said,
"Look, I know people are talking about
the index being overvalued, but it looks
pretty close to fairly valued."
And I'm moving on.
So, you can see the process of valuing
the index is very much like valuing a
company. In some ways, it's easier. You
don't have to worry about
company-by-company specifics.
But another level, you're making this
aggregate judgment.
So, after I finished this, you know, and
I said, "Look, I think this market is
fairly valued." I get people saying,
"Well, what if there's a recession
that's steeper than the one that you
predict?" The 15% drop in earnings was
roughly what US stocks have felt during
a recession going back 50 years.
But there have been worse recessions.
2008, for instance, the drop was closer
to 30%.
So, here's the word of question asked.
What if earnings are 30% below
estimates? This is actually a
catastrophic recession. And that the
T-bond rate instead of settling at 4%
becomes 5 or 6%. Here's the easy answer.
The higher rates become and the more
earnings are below estimates, the lower
the index level becomes.
And you can you can you can go across
you know, earnings are equal
Essentially, the higher rates become,
you're going to see the numbers drop
off.
So, as you go through time, you're
essentially going to see the numbers
shift depending on what you've assumed.
This actually should be earnings equal
to estimates. The 30% should be on
there, so I've switched the columns, but
the worse earnings come in below your
expectations, and the higher the
risk-free rate, the lower the index.
Do you remember what I valued the index
at on January 1st, 2025? It was the very
first valuation of the week. I'll be
very impressed if you remember, cuz I
had to look it up to remember.
I valued the index at about 5220.
The index was at 5899 at the start of
the year.
My conclusion was it's about 12 and 1/2%
overvalued. And that was before Trump
and tariffs and all the rest of the
chaos.
The market started the year at a really
high level. So, almost set
to correct part of it.
So, if I were valuing the index today, I
should update the value today. Tell me
what is coming to this process, the big
questions.
But let's step back. What can you know,
earnings have not changed dramatically
yet, right? There's talk of it changing.
Why?
Tariffs and trade war, so that's a big
issue. How will trade wars play out
in the earnings? Could the dividends and
buyback part of it? So, if there's a
trade war and you're uncertain,
companies are going to hold back.
What about the denominator?
Interest rates and equity risk premiums.
First, what drives equity risk premiums?
Fear
and worry, right?
So, you could talk about how this
week-to-week shock therapy for the
market is pushing up equity risk
premiums.
And there's also talk, will the trade
war play out as higher inflation, right?
If you've got to pay 30% more for
Canadian lumber,
and your furniture comes from Canada,
you are going to see them.
So, every number is now
kind of open to scrutiny, right?
So, that 5200 might very well have
become 5,000 by the time you work
through those numbers.
So, if you get a chance, download that
very first valuation of the week.
But now with the hindsight of, you know,
six, eight, nine weeks of data, ask
yourself, what would I change there?
Because otherwise, you're going to get
swept up in the mood of the moment where
people say everything is overvalued,
everything is undervalued. We're in a
bubble, we're not in a bubble.
Now, the chaos that's going to ensue
from the part of the reason I wrote the
piece that I sent the link to you
yesterday
was I was feeling a little unsettled.
Cuz the world that I grew up in and
since I'm much older, much, much older
than you, the world you all grew up in
seems to be shifting under you, right?
Because for much of my lifetime,
the world was moving inexorably to a
more globalized environment, right?
Globalization seemed to be unstoppable.
The second force, of course, is
disruption, which has changed companies,
and that too
seems to be coming for politics and
government. This is in a sense a coming
together, Because whenever I feel
unsettled, I have to step back. I call
it elevation. Step back rather than get
caught up in the in whatever the new
story is.
So, you get a chance to read it because
it tells you where I'm standing now.
Now, you've seen the Winnie the Pooh
movies. You You got You have to find
your happy place. Or if not your happy
place, your least unhappy place.
Because if you start you know, if you
let yourself get swung around by the
news of the moment, you are going to be
caught up in whatever react the thing
others are doing.
So,
any questions on that in valuing the
entire index. For those of you want to
take a pick different index to value,
take the Sensex. Down what 30% since
last September. Has it dropped by
enough? Is Indian Are Indian stocks
finally a bargain? The best way to
answer it
is make your best judgments, put in the
estimates, see what you get.
So, what I'd like to talk about next is
what I'm going to call the dark side of
valuation. Sounds ominous.
But I'm going to step back to that very
first class in intrinsic valuation where
we talked about what you're trying to do
in intrinsic valuation.
The way I think about the intrinsic
value of a company is you're trying to
answer four big questions about your
company. So, think about whatever
company you're valuing for your project.
Here are the four questions I'm trying
to get the answer for.
First, what are your cash flows from
existing investments, things you've
already done. Where are you going to get
the answer? You're going to go look at
the company's financial statements and
their history.
You're trying to answer it. Second, what
is the value you're going to get
or destroy by trying to grow? Notice how
I framed that. Growth by itself can add
value, destroy value. What's the value
added or destroyed by future growth?
What am I going to look at? I'm going to
look at the return on capital, get a
sense of a you know, good business, what
your competitive advantages are.
Value of growth.
What are your cash flows from existing
assets? What's the value of growth?
How risky are your cash flows? Notice I
didn't ask you what your beta is.
Systematic we use to convert risk to a
discount rate. How risky are your cash
flows? That goes in your discount rate.
And finally, when will you be a mature
company? Why do I need the answer to
that question?
That's when I stop estimating cash flows
and estimate a terminal value.
Every valuation is about answering those
four questions. The risk of stating the
obvious, when those four questions are
easy to answer,
valuation becomes easy.
So, those of you within a group, some of
you in the other people in the group
might be just coasting. You say, "How
come you're coasting? I'm getting
tortured here."
They picked a nice money-making company
with a lot of history.
Those questions become easy to answer.
So, when I talk about the dark side of
valuation, it's about companies where
those questions become difficult to
answer.
And let me give you at least three
groups and then I'll flesh them out. The
first is if you're valuing a young
company.
Think of what each of the questions,
think of why they get more difficult to
answer. And then you're going to see
that valuation becomes more difficult.
Second,
companies that don't fit the accounting
mold. Why? Because we get our data from
financial statements, right?
Earnings, CapEx, depreciation. When
accountants are screwing up on those
numbers because of consistency issues,
your valuation got more difficult.
Valuing a pharmaceutical company is
always more difficult than valuing a
manufacturing company cuz front end of
capitalizing R&D. And finally, we talked
about discrete risk. Companies that face
nationalization risk, distress risk.
Discounted cash flow valuation tends to
break down because discount rates were
not designed for that kind of risk.
So, here's what I'm going to start with.
I'm going to start by listing group of
companies or listed companies
that are difficult to value.
In fact, one of my books is called the
dark side of valuation precisely to
value these difficult to value
companies. First is across the life
cycle. Young companies are going to be
more difficult to value. So, we'll start
with those because to me that is the
test of whether you truly get valuation.
Mature companies are usually easy to
value, right? Unless they're trying to
restructure and become something else.
So, we're going to talk about what what
happens when companies restructure. Why
is it more difficult to value companies?
Third, declining companies are a
nightmare to value. I absolutely hate
valuing them. Not because mechanically
it's difficult, but psychologically. I
mean, I feel like taking a shower three
or four times in the course of valuing
the company because there's so much bad
stuff you got to build into the story.
Brick-and-mortar retail. Unless you want
to torture yourself, don't pick a
brick-and-mortar company retail company
in the US to value.
There's no happy ending that I can give
for this company.
You're saying, "What about Walmart?"
Walmart might be you know, last man
standing. But I would say other than
Walmart and Costco, I can't think of a
single other brick-and-mortar company in
the US where I see a happy ending at
that.
So, across the life cycle.
Across markets, I want to talk a little
bit about emerging market companies.
What makes them tricky to value? But I'm
not going to break the rules. The value
of a company is the present value of the
expected cash flows. That still applies.
We'll talk about what makes emerging
market companies tricky. And across
sectors,
I'm going to start with banks.
In my the books I wrote, the editions of
my books pre-2008,
in the chapter or section on valuing
banks, I used to start with a statement
that I've never ever quite lived down.
I would start the chapter by saying,
"Valuing banks is easy."
And I'll tell you what drove me to make
that statement and why I thought valuing
banks is easy and why I no longer think
that. The world has shifted under me.
We'll talk about what's changed banks.
I want to talk about commodity
companies. What makes commodity
companies tricky to value? An oil
company or a coal mining company.
Let's be very clear. Risk comes from
where?
Let's say a bit Ultimately, you're part
You're an oil company. How do the
geopolitics play out?
In the oil price, right? It's really
everything rides on macro variables. So,
when you're valuing a company, even for
a mature company, you're looking over
your shoulder at the macro environment.
We talk about what do we do about it.
You're valuing a cyclical company.
Everything can come apart if the economy
goes into recession.
And finally, I want to talk about
companies with intangible assets. That
R&D capitalization and show what it does
when you turn it off and on.
So, lots on our agenda. Let's start with
valuing young companies. You're You're
going to be my
my guinea pig here. You're going to be
an entrepreneur. You're going to start a
business with lots of potential. What
business you want to be in?
AI. How about AI? Yeah?
You started an AI business, lots of
potential. You started last week.
So, today I'm going to come to you with
the four questions and try your best to
give me an answer.
I'm going to ask you, "What are your
value What
What's the value of the cash flows from
existing assets?" What's your answer
going to be?
You started the business last week.
You're saying, "What existing assets?
I don't even own the chair I live in."
So, that was easy. I ask you, "What's
the value from future growth?"
You can't give me a number. You say it's
a lot. Can you be more specific? I have
no idea. I don't have a product in the
market.
How risky are you valuing?
Beyond that, what else can you offer me?
When will you be a mature company? You
fall out of your chair laughing saying,
"I don't even know whether I'll make it
through next week."
You see how these questions become
nightmares to answer? So, what do most
company most people do with the young
companies? They don't value them.
VCs price them. They don't value them.
And the defense they offer is there's
too much uncertainty.
I'm going to push against it, but you
can see where they're coming from. Every
question becomes difficult to answer.
We load the dice up and make it even
more difficult.
Take AI companies, right? Every AI
company you look at is going to look
just like
All companies where you have nothing to
show for cash flows from existing
assets, value of growth, and risk are
fuzzy.
If every company is just like your
company, here's your nightmare scenario.
I call this evaluation trifecta.
Basically, when you value companies, you
go to three places to get information.
The company's financials,
the company's history, and other
companies in the sector. Where you make
up for the loss loss of one by looking
at the other.
If you're in a business where every
company is a young startup or a young
company, think of what you have, right?
Your financials tell you nothing about
your company. You have no history.
And if every other company looks like
yours, the comparable companies tell you
very little about the sector.
This is when the dark side will beckon.
They won't say They'll say things like,
"Oh, in this business, value doesn't
matter. It doesn't matter whether you
make money. That's old economy. We're
new economy."
And every time you ask them, "Why should
I
value a company at 15 billion?" their
answer will be a macro story.
Why should I value company 15 billion?
AI.
China.
Dot-com.
Very suspicious, but it means that they
can't tell you. It's a big market. It's
to give me a high number, right?
Remember that big market delusion. And
they'll be talk about paradigm shifts
and how the world has changed and the
old rules don't apply.
Where When I used to do these seminars
in the 1990s, I used to go go up and out
talk to the CFA about valuation.
And I'd do a discounted cash flow
valuation session. Somebody'd come up to
me at the end of the session.
They'd very in a very aggressive way
start pushing their finger at me and
say, "You really can't value amazon.com
using a discounted cash flow model, can
you?"
The way they ask that question, you know
exactly the answer they wanted from you.
No, no, do whatever you want.
But stupidly, at the risk of grave
personal injury, I'd say, "No, you can
value Amazon using a discounted cash
flow model."
And they'd give me this look of total
contempt.
Say, "Academic."
And the way they said it was not meant
as a compliment. Basically means you
really can talk but you can't do it. And
after the fifth or sixth time of being
called a academic,
I got really pissed off.
That's when I valued Amazon for the
first time.
In fact, I'm going to show you a
valuation of Amazon I did in January
2000. And as you look at this valuation,
I want you to forget everything Amazon's
done since then because you can't bring
the benefit of hindsight.
So, here's what Amazon looked like in
January 2000.
Step back. January 2000, the NASDAQ had
just hit 5,000. It was the peak of the
dot-com boom, and amazon.com was the
poster child
for the dot-com business.
In the 12 months leading into January
2000, Amazon had revenues of $1.1
billion.
For a US retailer, revenues of $1.1
billion is tiny.
In fact, even in 2000, Walmart had $250
billion revenues, Gap at $16 billion.
Amazon was a company with tiny revenues.
And an operating loss of $110 million.
Right? So, you have a company with small
revenues and big operating losses.
It's going to sound like a stupid
question, but humor me. Can a company
with small revenues and big operating
losses become a valuable company? So,
fear, help me out.
For a company with small revenues and
big operating losses,
what has to happen?
What if No, if the revenue stays small
and the margins improve, they're not
going to become valuable. So, first the
small revenues have to become
big revenues, right? So, it's incredibly
simplistic, and the losses have to
become
profits. Can't just shrink. The losses
have to change sign.
I'm going to give you the first two key
inputs that drive the value of young
companies. And you're going to see the
Ginzu spreadsheet kind of get created as
we go along.
How do I get small revenues to big
revenues? I need a revenue growth
number, right?
Good. What do I need to make my margins
positive? I need a target margin, a
margin you can sustain after you've gone
through your growth pains. So, I'll give
you the numbers I used in January 2000
for Amazon. And as I said, not fair
using the benefits of hindsight. In In
2000, I thought Amazon was going to
become a retail company. I really liked
the company. I really liked Jeff Bezos,
and I thought they were going to
succeed.
With that background, I gave them a 42%
compounded revenue growth rate. I'll
come and explain why 42, why not 45, 36,
38.
42% compounded revenue growth rate for
the next 10 years.
This was a
webcast, a very, very primitive, early
webcast I did for AIMR, which is the
parent organization for the CFA.
I was doing the webcast. I finished
saying 42% compounded growth rate. I get
an email question. You couldn't directly
ask questions then on webcasts.
And the email question says, "How come
you're being so pessimistic about future
growth?"
You know what a 42% compounded growth
rate does to $1.1 billion revenues? Take
a look at my revenues over time. My $1.1
billion revenues becomes $41 billion by
the time I get to year 11. I'm
increasing revenues 40-fold over the
next decade, and you're accusing me of
being pessimistic.
But why did it sound pessimistic? What
were they comparing it to?
They were looking at last year's growth
rate, which was 200%. They said, "How
come you" They missed the compounded in
the 10 years. I wasn't using 42% every
year. I was actually using 150% in year
one, but as the company got bigger, I
had to scale down the growth rates
because the base was getting bigger.
I thought I was being pretty upbeat. You
can still push me on why 42%, why not
45, why not 39. I'll talk about how I
came up with the 42%. Half my problem
has been fixed, right? My small revenues
have become big revenues.
So, my second problem? I'm losing a ton
of money. My margin right now is -36.7.
Let's take the easy route out first. If
I expect the margin to stay -36.7%
forever,
what's the value of Amazon?
It's going to go to zero, right? Go go
bankrupt.
So, the question is, what will margins
look like for Amazon
if they make it in succeed? Now, I
already laid the foundation. I saw
Amazon as a retail company,
and I thought it was going to succeed.
So, guess where I went looking for what
a margin would look like if they
succeeded.
I went looked at brick-and-mortar retail
companies.
Not dot-com retail companies. They're
all losing money like Amazon. I said,
"Once these companies become retail
companies, there is an economics to the
business. Gross margins are gross
margins, whether you're brick-and-mortar
And I went to the 75th percentile
of retail companies. Remember I said
every valuation I'm telling a story.
What kind of story do you hear from from
me on Amazon? Upbeat story?
Basically increasing revenues 40-fold
and margins at the 75th percentile.
It's 10%. We'll talk about how I got
from -36.7 to +10, but I've got the two
big numbers nailed down. If my revenue
growth comes through and margins
improve, this company's going to go from
a small money-losing company in year one
to a large money-making company by the
time I get to year 10.
There's one final loose end, though.
To get my revenues from a billion to 41
billion, it's going to require
reinvestment. In what?
God only knows, right? Could be CapEx,
could be acquisitions, could be R&D, it
could be computer technology.
And you know what? Jeff Bezos wouldn't
have known either. So, trying to break
down this reinvestment is an exercise in
futility. So, what am I going to do? I'm
going to estimate it as a collective
number, and this is where I got stuck
the longest when I first valued Amazon
because nothing in the textbooks,
including my own, helped me.
Think of some of the ways we estimate
growth. Or estimate reinvestment. We
look at historical CapEx and
depreciation.
That's not going to work for a young
company. There's not much history.
You could do the return on capital
reinvestment rate. That's not going to
work here here either because you're
losing money. Your return capital is
negative.
It took me about, I think, a week
to finally say, "Look, I can't focus on
earnings. I got to focus on revenues."
And I have to tie how much I reinvest to
how much my revenues are growing.
Hence was born the sales to capital
ratio. The first time I used sales
invested capital was when I valued
Amazon because I needed it to get the
reinvestment each year. And I used three
as my sales to capital ratio. Where am I
getting that? Looking across all retail
firms,
I compute the sales sales, basically the
revenues. Invested capital is book debt
plus equity minus cash, the same base
for. And I compute for every retail
firm. And here again, I gave Amazon the
75th
percentile. Essentially, that they'd be
more efficient in delivering growth than
the typical retail firm. And here's a
good reason, right? You don't have
brick-and-mortar stores. You should be
able to do it. So, I've told you a
pretty collectively a pretty upbeat
story.
High revenue growth, improving margins,
fairly efficient reinvestment.
I'm making my company go from small
money-losing to big money-making. Stay
on that theme.
What's the cost of capital supposed to
measure? The risk in your company,
right? Is the risk in Amazon on my
spreadsheet going to be different in
year five than from year one?
Yeah? It's going to be bigger. It's
going to be making money. In year 10,
it's a mature retail company.
So, if you look at my cost of capital,
it starts at 12.84%, almost entirely
equity funded because it couldn't afford
that, with a high beta. And we'll talk
about where I got the beta. And by the
time you get to year 10, that cost of
capital is down to 9.6%.
The die has been cast. I've got the cash
flows. I've got these changing discount
rates.
But if you look at the cash flows in my
upbeat story, I want to emphasize the
word upbeat. What are my cash flows in
year one?
Forget the base year. It's -930 million.
Year two, minus a billion. Year three,
minus a billion. Year four, negative,
negative,
In my upbeat story, my cash flows are
negative. You know why? Because I'm so
upbeat. Sounds like a weird thing to
say, but the more ambitious I get,
the more negative my cash flows are
going to be. Why is that?
Is I'm putting in a higher growth rate?
If I'm putting in a higher growth rate,
the reinvestment is going to go up. This
is a feature, not a bug. So, as I get
more upbeat, my cash flows are going to
be negative. I am implicitly assuming
that Amazon's going to be able to raise
capital to be keep going through the
next six years. I was being a little too
optimistic in hindsight.
But I've got my cash flows. I've got my
cost of capital. I discount the cash
flows back. And when your cost of
capital changes, it's a mechanical
thing, and I think I've talked about
this. You got to compute the compounded
number. To discount the cash flow in
year seven, you got to take the cash
cost of capital for the first five
years, then year six, then year seven.
I discount the cash flows back. I get a
value of 15.2 billion. Incidentally,
after year 10 for Amazon, I gave them a
growth rate of 6% a year forever. You
couldn't get away doing that today,
right? But what is it about 2000 that
allowed me to use such a high growth
rate in perpetuity?
Right there, right? 6 and 1/2% T-bond
rate.
It's a different time.
I take the present value, the value that
I get is 15.2 billion. Add cash, almost
nothing. Subtract that almost nothing.
And then I stop and subtract out equity
options.
So, Amitha, what what what equity
options am I subtracting out here to get
to the value?
What do you think those are?
You're a shareholder in a company. What
are the options that a company might
grant that hurt the value of your
equity?
Anytime you give options to employees,
it's a piece of your equity being I'm
not saying it's a bad thing to do, but
it's not free, right? And during the
1990s, tech companies gave options away
like they were free money. We talked
about this. I'm subtracting. Now, do you
see why that I spent that time on
options?
They've given away a quarter of the
company pretty much over the last over
their lifetime. I subtract that out,
then I divide by the shares outstanding,
I get a value per share of $35.
I want you to hold me accountable. Every
company I value, after I give you the
value and I tell you what the market
price is, I want you to ask the
question.
Value per share that I get for Amazon is
$35, right?
The stock price
is 84.
So, what's the question you'd ask me to
see if I trust my own valuation, believe
my own valuation?
Would I short the stock? If it were
undervalued, yes, would I buy?
And my answer when I was asked this at
the end of this is not in this lifetime.
And people say, "Don't you feel
confident enough?" I feel more confident
that Amazon is overvalued in 2000 than
in some of the stocks that I'm going to
show you as undervalued a little later
in the process.
So, why am I unwilling to short the
stock?
Yeah, but you could say they're
undervalued as well, right? Corrections.
So, why am I willing to make that bet
about markets not correcting?
So, let's stop there. Would I buy When I
buy a stock because it's undervalued,
how long am I willing to wait?
I'm not a portfolio manager. I don't
have no clients. I only have to explain
this to my spouse.
And I turned off the statements from our
brokerage house a while back. She has no
idea what we're owning. So, I can wait
and wait, and then when she finds out 11
years from now, I can blame the kids.
They must have hit some buy button and
that
I can wait as long as it takes
before it corrects. I control my time
horizon.
This is one of the biggest advantages
that you and I I have over portfolio
managers.
Cuz portfolio managers can tell you
they're long term, but who they have to
answer to? Their clients. You don't have
a client. Your client is you, and as
long as you're patient with yourself,
when I sell short, what am I doing?
I'm borrowing shares
and agreeing to return them
whenever I'm asked for them.
I actually, before I did this valuation,
I checked around to see how long a
broker would give me if I sold short.
You know the most I got was?
4 weeks. And he was doing it as a favor.
He said, "Dot-com stocks right now, the
demand is too high. I will give you 4
weeks."
Now, do you see why selling short
is much more difficult than intrinsic
valuation than going long? Because you
don't control your time horizon. Not
only do I have to be right, the market
has to correct within 4 weeks, and
there's zero. Which
What is the implication of this? When
you have bubbles, they're far more
likely to be upside bubbles than
downside bubbles, because it's very
difficult to create long-term
strategies. Not impossible.
Remember the housing bubble?
2006, 2007. The people had noticed it,
but what the heck were you going to do?
Go sell your neighbor's house short?
I don't even know how that works. Can I
borrow your house for a few months, sell
it?
But there were a couple of people who
figured out creative ways. You're
sitting in a room funded by one of those
people.
You know what this room was originally
called, right? What's the
It's Paulson Auditorium, named after
John Paulson. There are two Paulsons,
very confusing. There's Hank Paulson,
who was the Secretary of the Treasury.
There's John Paulson.
John Paulson runs a hedge fund, and he
made
billions of dollars
by selling short on housing using
mortgage-backed securities as his
vehicle.
Very creative.
Right?
But finding long-term bets to make is
really tough to do. So, you can see the
asymmetry in this.
Any questions about the big picture?
Because I'm going to zero in on some of
the things I learned when I valued
Amazon that still come into play when I
value young companies. So, if you're
valuing a young company, maybe there's
something in what I do that might help
you in that valuation.
The first is how we get betas for
companies. We did a bottom-up beta,
right? Looking at the peer group.
With Amazon, I did two bottom-up betas.
For the first 5 years, I used the
unlevered beta for just dot-com
retailers.
Why? Cuz my argument is they probably
have higher fixed costs, younger
companies. That beta was 1.60.
But by the time I get to year five,
Amazon has $15 billion in revenues, is
making a billion and a half in profits.
I said, "At that point, when I think of
Amazon, I'll think retail first and
online later." So, after year five, I
moved the beta towards a beta for all
retailers. So, two different betas.
But the one thing you shouldn't do is
never run a regression. So, you're
valuing a young company and running a
regression, here's what you're going to
see. In the case of Amazon, my raw beta
was 2.23. That's good, right?
But then you look at the standard error
of the beta. Do you notice what it is?
0.50, which means my true beta can be
anywhere from 1.2 to 3.2. Running a
regression beta on a young company is a
complete waste of time, and it's
extremely dangerous. Do bottom-up betas,
even if it means doing two different
segments.
Second stop. Let's talk about that 42%
and the 10% target.
When I first valued Amazon, I did my
valuation the way I was taught to do it
where the way I was teaching other
people to do it, which is sequential.
You know what I mean by sequentially?
You do cash flows in year one, then year
two, then year three, then year four.
And I was discovering that I was pulling
my hair out at a rate that I'd be bald
by the time I got to year seven.
Why? Because I was getting more and more
uncertain as I went further into time.
So, I stepped back and said, "This isn't
working for me."
And I'm going to say something that's
going to sound mildly Deepak
Chopra-like, and I hate the guy, so
don't take it as a Chopra.
You almost have to visualize what
success will look like at the at a young
company to value. What does that mean? I
stepped back and said, "Look, you know,
I think Amazon's going to win. I think
it's going to be a successful retail
company. I'm going to give it the
numbers of a successful retail company."
So, how the hell are you going to answer
that question? I went and collected the
20 largest retailers in the world in
2000.
Walmart. None of them were dot-com
retailers. They're all brick and mortar
retailers. And then I asked myself a
question. 10 years from now, assuming
what I know about Amazon is a fair,
where on this list would I see Amazon?
First looked at the top of the list.
Will it be bigger than Walmart? And in
2000, my conclusion is I don't think so.
It's not a discount retailer. Will it be
as small as Ann Taylor? I don't think
so, because they just sell apparel.
So, I went back and forth, and I ended
up between the fifth and sixth. I said,
"That's where they're going to put."
Guess what the revenues of the fifth and
sixth largest retailer, just for
inflation, was.
About 40 to 42 billion.
That became my end revenue.
You're saying, "How the heck did he get
these numbers by year, the revenue
growth rates?"
I made them up.
You didn't miss hear me. I made them up.
And if you made a big deal about any of
these numbers, I'll give them to you.
So, if you said in year one, I think the
growth is going to be 163%,
you can have that one. How about year
two? Take that, too. You give me the
starting and ending numbers in this
valuation.
I control the valuation. It's the end
game that drives the value of a young
company.
So, could I have had a bigger end game
for Amazon? Absolutely.
At that time, though, I thought $42
billion was a pretty big end game.
My margins right now are minus 36.7. I
told you where I got the 10 10% is the
75th percentile.
You're saying, "How the heck did you get
these margins in year It looks awfully
precise. It's almost like I had a
crystal ball telling me what the margins
would be in year one and year two."
I want you to take a look at the margins
on that table, minus 13.35, minus and
try to guess
what I did to get them. And I'll give
you a clue. It was a very simple
algorithm. I turned the computer loose
and say, "Fill in all the numbers, cuz
I'm not doing it."
Don't try. What What do you think I did?
No, to get the margins in year two,
three. The revenue growth I just made
up. I just need to get to 42 billion.
What
But I That's a direction, right? So, but
how did I get the numbers themselves,
you think? Sophia?
It's a little too messy. I don't want
anything that would bring in logs,
exponents, etc. I'll give you a clue.
What Where am I right now, Sophia?
What's my starting point? Minus
Where do I want to be?
I took half the distance to my goal.
Take the difference, divide by two. It
brings me to minus 13.35. Minus 13.35,
10. I took half. You're saying, "Why
half?" Why not?
I need to get to 10, right? And when I
design spreadsheets, my objective is if
you disagree with me, which you should,
I want you to give a number to change.
By assuming halfway to my target, I'm
assuming a fairly
comfortable pathway to profitability,
right? Smooth. Let's say you agree with
every other part of my valuation, but
you say, "I don't think Amazon is going
to get to 10% as smoothly. It's going to
be a lot more rocky." You know what you
should do? Take the half, make it a
quarter.
What'll happen then? I'll still have the
same starting point. I'll have the same
same ending point. I'm going to lose
money for 7 and 1/2 8 years, and I'm
going to lose more money up front.
You're more optimistic than me? Make it
one. In which case, what will you do?
Your margin will go from -36 to +10 next
year, and you go That's an extremely up
being.
When you build valuation models, build
them in a way that people can disagree
with you and adjust it. Because if you
build in some elaborate mathematical
progression here, they don't even know
where to start.
So, my lord. So, if you take those
margins, my margins give rise to my
operating income. Year one, my operating
income is -373. Obviously, I don't pay
taxes. Year two, I'm still losing money,
no taxes. Year three, I make money, but
I still don't pay taxes. How come?
Yes.
I carry my losses. Best way to deal with
NOLs in a DCF is to keep track of them
and save taxes while you have them. And
once you run out of them, so if you look
at my Ginzburg spreadsheet, I keep track
of your NOLs. So, if you lose more
money, I make your NOL actually more
bigger over time, and then I use it to
save you taxes, because that's how NOLs
work.
I've got my after-tax operating. And
while you're doing all of this, you're
probably saying, "Why did you give
Amazon only 10 years of growth?"
Seems a little unfair in hindsight,
right? Because Amazon 25 years later is
still growing
at rates faster than the economy.
In 2000, I didn't know that would
happen.
But one of the reasons I stop at 10,
that the Ginzburg spreadsheet stops at
10,
is because about 25 or 30 years ago, I
started looking at growth companies. And
later on, I found a study that looked at
IPOs,
and compared the growth rate in an in
revenues for an IPO to the growth rate
of the sector that the IPOs. Remember,
IPOs are usually of the highest growth
companies.
So, 1 year after the IPO, the IPO's
revenue growth rate is 15% higher than
the sector. Two years later, it's 7%
higher. Three years later, it's 3%
higher. By the time you get to year
five,
the IPO's growth rate looks very much
like the sector. You're saying, "So,
what?" Revenue fades really fast at most
companies. Most companies,
their growth rates don't last more than
three, four, five years. By the time I
get to 10, I'm already at the 90th
percentile
of growth periods for growth companies.
And I'm going to stop at the 90th
percentile, because we grow for longer
than 10 years, I want that to be icing
on the cake for me as an investor.
So, when you complain, look at that
Ginzburg spreadsheet with your company
and say, "If only it let me go for 20
years."
Hey, you're welcome to take the
spreadsheet and adjust for 20 years. But
then, remember, if you get an
undervalued company,
your company now has to grow for 20
years for you to break even.
That's one more barrier for it to
overcome as an investor.
So,
we talked about growth earlier on in
this class, right? What was the rule?
When you have to grow, you have to
reinvest. But you can't forget that rule
just because you're looking at a young
company. And here, as I said, the key
number that allowed me to break through
was that sales to capital ratio. How
does that help me? Every year, I compute
the change in revenues,
divide by three, I've got the
reinvestment. That's it. I'm done.
And you go to the next year, take the
change in revenues, divide by three.
Which means the higher the sales to
capital rate, the more efficiently I'm
delivering growth. Another lever that
drives value.
That sales to capital ratio is what we
talked about earlier in the class about
should it be a high number or a low
number? Are you capital intensive
business? You have excess capacity, that
becomes the key number that you should
use. But again, remember, the higher
that number, the less you're
reinvesting. The lower that number, the
more I'm asking for reinvestment.
And each year, that reinvestment becomes
the change in invested capital. This is
something we tend to forget. But if
you're valuing a company and you're
estimating reinvestment, it's the delta
in your invested capital. You can keep
track of your own invested capital, and
look at what you're estimating as return
on capital based on your assumptions
about growth and reinvestment.
When you build spreadsheets, there's
always this danger that you're building
a fairy tale. That by the time you get
to year 10, you're building a company
that no one has ever seen something like
this before. That return capital in year
10 is feedback from my own spreadsheet
about whether I'm reinvesting too much,
too little, or just the right amount. In
fact, for Amazon, that number was
20.39%,
which in 2000, I was pretty okay with,
because that's you know, remember,
T-bond rates were 6 and 1/2%. Retail
firms were earning 18 to 20%. But if
that return on capital had been 200.39%
in year 10, what's my spreadsheet
telling me?
You're not reinvesting enough. And if
that's if the if I listen, I can go
lower my sales to capital ratio,
reinvest more, so it becomes a way of
tweaking your spreadsheet to make sure
you're reinvesting enough.
Now, of course, with the case of Amazon,
you have those negative cash flows, they
would require share issuances, and we
talked about this before.
When you require share issuances, the
number of shares is going to rise over
time. And you're going to feel this
incentive, "Should I adjust my share
count now?"
But you shouldn't, because if you take
the present value of the negative cash
flows, so if you go back and look at the
valuation,
those negative cash flows, those first
six years of negative cash flows lower
my value from 20 billion down to 15
billion. In effect, I've reduced the
present value because I've negative
My dilution is already built in. I
shouldn't be adjusting the share count
as well for the expected share
issuances, cuz that would be double
counting. So, good news on intrinsic
valuation of young companies, it's not
that you're rejecting the idea that
there will be issuances, but those
equity issuances have already been built
into your valuation. Implicitly, you're
assuming equity will be issued at the
intrinsic value, which is what makes
sense in an intrinsic valuation. But
there's no need to keep track of future
share count. You just divide by the
shares today.
But you know, I think we meant to be
talked about a little bit about failure
rates earlier, but let me be explained.
Most young companies
don't make it to year two or year three.
I think 2/3 of startups don't make it to
year two.
With mature companies, you can ignore
this. Just do a DCF and you're done.
With young companies, you have to
incorporate the likelihood of failure.
This is actually one of my favorite data
sets. It's maintained by the Bureau of
Labor Statistics. It's a government
database. And here's what they do. They
track all startups every year. This
immense database.
And then, they track how many of the
startups make it to year one, to year
two, year three. So, this is I think the
2006 cohort of all companies. So, you
look at that cohort broken down by
business. Let's take a particular
business. Let's take, you know, health
care.
18.6% of health care companies that
start up fail in year one. By the time
you get to year year five, 44% have
failed. By the time you get to year 10,
almost 70% of health care startups have
failed.
You're saying, "What's the significance
of year 10? What happens in year 10 in
our DCFs?"
You get to see Nirvana, right?
What form does it take? A huge terminal
value. Remember, without this, you're up
a creek without a paddle.
And if 70% of companies don't make it to
Nirvana, you're that value you computed
becomes almost useless.
So, with young companies, here's the
final with I didn't do this for Amazon
2000. I confess, I was far too
optimistic. You got to estimate a
failure rate and bring in. And if you
look at that Ginzburg spreadsheet, there
is an input, so will your company fail?
And if you say yes, you can estimate a
number.
Because that's the way you put in that
closure.
So, I finished this valuation,
and somebody in the audience, somebody
must have been somebody owned Amazon,
puts up her hand and says,
"Could Amazon be worth $84 per share? Is
it possible?" What's the answer to that?
Answer where possible is such a weak
word. In fact, we know exactly what we
need to do to get to $84. Use a higher
revenue growth or higher margins.
So, what I actually did was I just
played with those numbers. It's actually
very simple once you've spread it. And
what was I looking for? Values that
exceeded $84. See those shaded areas?
The combination you need is a much
higher revenue growth than the 42% that
I used or a much higher margin.
It's another way of rephrasing how you
think about intrinsic valuation. It's a
break-even point.
You can compute the break-even point for
your company. Ask, "Am I comfortable
with that being my break-even point?"
So, lots of eyes to dot and tees to
cross,
but you can value young companies.
So, the final question I was asked was,
"Are you sure you're right?"
And I said, "I'm sure I'm wrong."
Why? Because I'm trying to forecast the
future.
You're going to be wrong 100%
of the time, and it's okay.
And here's why it's okay. You don't have
to be right to make money, you just have
to be less wrong than everybody else.
That's basically what it brings down the
level of anxiety, cuz you're going to
beat yourself up as you do your value.
How do I know I'm right? I'll save you
the trouble. You're definitely wrong.
It's okay to be wrong.
Just try to be a little less wrong than
everybody else. That's what this whole
process is about.
So, I valued Amazon in 2000, found it to
be dramatically overvalued, right? I
didn't sell short. And I gave you the
little song and dance.
A year later, I revisited my Amazon
valuation. You said, "What can happen in
12 months?"
You know what happened in those 12
months between January 2000 and January
2001?
The dot-com boom bust, the economy went
into recession.
The world shifted under me. So, I
revalued Amazon. Just give me a sense of
direction. I'm now valuing Amazon in a
much riskier world with much less
optimism about the coming dot-com
retail. Is my value going to go up or
down?
It's going to go down. In fact, the
value that I got was $20. I did it for a
second webcast for the AIMR. And
somebody raised the question of, "Aren't
you uncomfortable that your value went
change by so much from 34 to 20?"
If you think
I changed my mind going from 34 to 20,
how would you characterize what the
market did when the stock went from 84
down to 11?
And I was trapped.
You know I was trapped?
A year ago, what was the question you
asked?
Are you selling short? And then I did
the song and dance about time horizon.
Now I was asked the same question. Now,
what's the question going to be?
And now I have no excuse, right? I
bought Amazon for the first time
in 2001.
What's the old value in
investing? I had it you buy and forget.
Don't do that with stocks like Amazon or
Tesla.
I bought.
And then the next year
the price went up. So, I should sell,
right?
But I revalued again. The next year,
both the value and the price went up,
but it was still undervalued. So, it
stayed in my portfolio. 2003,
I revalued again. The value went up by
almost 100%, but the price went up
almost 200%.
It's time to leave. I bought Amazon five
times in the last 25 years. I've sold it
four times. I've kind of told you where
I am right now by giving you the map.
These are not the kinds of companies you
buy and forget. They require I mean,
that's part of the reason for my kids, I
don't put them into individual stocks.
I'm somehow become their fund manager.
Don't ask me why.
I put them into mutual funds because
when you're in individual companies, it
comes with maintenance work. Right? You
got to revisit. You got to ask yourself,
should it still stay? And you take
stocks like Tesla and Nvidia, that
maintenance work can be six times a
year, right? So, so many things can
change so quickly.
So, any questions on valuing young
companies? So, as you look at this
process, you can see
how I think about young companies being
formed because this I speeded up the
process. When I originally did it for
Amazon, each of these required getting
over
ways in which I'd always been thinking
about growth and reinvestment.
But essentially the end game.
So, I did that in 2000, right? I almost
never look back because nothing is
gained by looking back.
But in 2014, I went back and looked at
Amazon's actual numbers to see how close
or far away. This is a very dangerous
game to play, right? But if you if your
head is getting too big, it's a great
game to play because it's, "Oh my god, I
was that off?"
So, I wanted to compare how close I got
to my 2000 numbers. So, there's my
forecast. Those are the actual revenues.
So, my forecast ended in 2010.
Yeah.
41 billion, they were actually a little
below. By the time you get to 2013,
though, they're actually above. So,
basically, if I stopped at 10 years, I
was overshooting on revenues. But they
actually shot through.
They kept growing.
On the margins, I predicted that the
margins would go to 10%. They actually
went to about 4.11% and then they
reversed course and actually went down
again.
It's a very strange phenomenon, right?
Because you expect companies to mature,
their margins keep improving. You know
what Amazon did in 2011?
They actually decided that they didn't
want to be a retail company. If they'd
stayed in retail,
their revenues would have leveled off,
their margins would have improved.
But they decided that they were a
disruption machine. The story I told for
Amazon shifted fairly dramatically in
2011 and 12 because they weren't
behaving like a company approaching
maturity. They were starting to behave
again like a startup.
In fact, whenever I tell a story for a
company, I try to visualize an image
that kind of imprints that story.
Think of it Netflix, the image that
comes is a hamster on a wheel.
Because they have to produce content to
get subscribers, get
With Amazon,
you know what what I think of when I
value the company?
I think of Thanos.
Right?
Basically, this is a disruption machine,
right? They're going to target
businesses that they think are soft.
Eventually, they're going to click their
fingers and you're going to be turned to
dust, but you might take a few years to
get there.
It's the greatest disruption machine
I've seen in my lifetime. Right?
Now, when whenever, you know, Amazon
enters a business, I tell companies in
the business, "I don't know whether
Amazon will ever make money, but this
much I know, you will all make less
money from this day on."
It's almost like a death sentence to a
business when they enter because they
drive prices down, they drive margins
down.
A lot of businesses can't survive.
Right? The day Amazon bought Whole
Foods,
you know that
collectively, grocery store companies
lost almost $30 in market cap on that
one day?
Kroger, Walmart, Target. What does the
market say?
Amazon's going to screw up your
business.
Right?
In fact, there's there's If you go back
and look at all of the new businesses,
and there are some businesses I look at
and say, "Please let Amazon enter this
business."
JP Morgan charged me $50 to wire my own
money to myself.
I said, "I hope Amazon enters banking
and screws you guys over."
When the university charges you, how
much does NYU charge you now? $66,000
a year?
Please God, let there be an Amazon
university.
Or health care.
I mean, who came up with this incre- I
mean, you know the the classic business
for disruption. What are the things you
look for? You want it to be a big
business, right?
You want it to be inefficiently run and
nobody's happy.
There's nobody who's happy in the health
care business. You talk to doctors, they
complain about. You talk to patients,
you talk to hospitals. There isn't
anybody happy.
But how come
nobody's making money in this business?
Everybody's losing money. Where is 20%
of our GDP going?
And how do you manage to make everybody
unhappy with all these trillions of
dollars you spent?
Amazon has actually talked about
entering health care, but they've been
strangely reluctant, maybe because of
the regulatory components and the
kind of ethical issues that will come up
because you enter the health care
business.
But this is a disruption machine.
And the reason it's in my portfolio is,
you know, it's managed to find a way to
get to newer and higher levels of
revenues and value as you go through.
Now, somebody when I was valuing Amazon
in 2015, banker in the audience,
looked at my 2000 valuation and said,
"How did How come you didn't bring the
cloud business into your valuation?"
And I said, you know, "The only clouds I
was thinking about in 2000 were in the
sky."
You can't look back and say, "How come
you didn't bring in the AI business in
valuing Nvidia in 2018?" I didn't even
know there was such a business as an AI
business. You can do only what you can
do.
And companies will surprise you.
Hopefully, they'll surprise you in the
right direction, but sometimes will
surprise you in the wrong direction.
And your job is to adapt and adjust your
value.
So, this was my 2022 valuation
of Amazon. This was the latest
iteration, the last time I bought
Amazon. And you can see
value per share that I got was 3,746.
There's been since there've been
multiple splits, so you can't compare
the price today. That stock was trading
at 3,068.
So,
this is a company that hopefully one of
these days will settle into a point
where I just can leave it because I
don't like to constantly have to revisit
it. It's a company whose story has
clearly shifted over time, potential
revenues reflected. If you look at the
end revenue share, what's that number?
1.4 trillion dollars in revenues.
Amazon's already So, it's it's at 540
billion, right? It's the second largest
revenue in the world. I think the only
company with more revenues is Walmart,
and Amazon might have already have
crossed Walmart.
But if you're a disruption machine,
what's your end game? You could have
revenues from every conceivable business
I can see.
You know, the one thing that that scares
me in Amazon with every valuation, think
about the one thing that should scare
you. With Amazon,
I don't think any company can stop it,
but it could be stopped by the
government or regulators. And you know
what? They're going to be able to do it
cuz every one of Amazon's competitors,
in a pathetic show, will go to the
government and say, "You got to save us
from this company."
And that's the one thing that I think
can shut the company down. So, after
all, it's what stopped Alibaba and
Tencent, right? And the government
essentially says, "Okay, this is it."
That's the one thing you have to worry
about during the valuation, is can that
happen?
Now, Lina Khan did, you know, the
previous
FTC head.
Her PhD thesis at Yale as a lawyer was
about Amazon and how it needed to be
stopped cuz it was not good for the
collective good of people. Yeah.
But try telling that to somebody that
their $139 per year premium prime
membership is just too cheap and they
should be charged more. It's not exactly
a great sales pitch to make.
So, I'm not sure how the government will
stop it, but that's my one fear.
Talk about valuing mature companies.
Mature companies should be easy to
value, right? They've been around a long
time. They're set in their ways.
Can you be set into bad ways, though?
Every morning I wake up and I eat a Linz
a tart.
I know I shouldn't be doing it, but I
love raspberry jam. And as I'm eating
and I'm saying, "This is bad for me.
This is bad for me." But I'm set in my
ways.
I could go through a day and talk about
the things I shouldn't be doing that I
do because of mature companies can
sometimes get set in bad ways, right?
They do things that they've always done.
And sometimes somebody pushes them to
change. It usually requires an external
but an activist. So, you might have to
restructure. So, I'll give you an
example of what you have to do by using
the four questions again. So, let's say
you're looking at a company that is on
the verge of changing. Intel right now,
Starbucks. They're all companies that
are in trouble basically saying, "What
can they do?"
Whenever I ask each of the questions,
there are two possible answers you can
give me. One is the answer if they keep
doing what they're doing, and one is the
answer of what will happen if they
restructure.
So, then I ask you, "What are your cash
flows with existing assets?" You can
give me a number.
And then I say, "What would those cash
flows look like if they restructure?"
You give me a different number. What's
the value growth? You give me one number
with the existing management, one with
You're going to end up with two values
for the company, right? You're saying,
"What do I do with those two values?"
I'm going to give you an example with a
company called Hormel. Heard of Hormel?
It's most famous product is perhaps the
most disgusting thing I've seen passed
off as food.
It's called Spam.
First time I saw this, I couldn't
believe it. It's like ham in a can
with a life that can outlast three
nuclear winters.
How you put meat into a can and make it
last forever terrifies me.
But you know how Spam was created,
right? Does anybody know the history of
Spam?
In the 1940s,
at the night in 1945 specifically, when
the Second World War ended,
the US Army was trying to fly its troops
back from the Pacific back to the
mainland. And the planes wouldn't make
it. So, they'd have to stop midway. And
what's midway between the Pacific and
the US?
Hawaii.
So, you have tens of thousands of hungry
servicemen landing in Hawaii. And this
is not the Hawaii of today with
five-star hotels.
And a few pineapples to feed these
people, and perhaps if they're really
desperate, a few sweet potatoes and
yams. And these were not vegans.
They wanted meat. So, the US Army sent
out a requisition saying, "Somebody
figure out a way to get a lot of meat to
Hawaii,
but it can't be refrigerated.
So, we got to get it in cans." And
Hormel rose to the occasion. They
concocted Spam. That's why if you go to
Hawaii still, you can get Spam
cookbooks.
Kung Pao Spam,
Spam
pancakes,
Spam lasagna. It tastes disgusting every
conceivable way, but it's Spam in
everything.
So, Hormel kind of took off and it
became a successful food company. A lot
of food companies in the US were family
controlled. And Hormel was controlled by
the Hormel family. Think they were
Pennsylvania based.
And they were very conservatively run.
So, this is the valuation of Hormel with
their existing management in place. The
existing management place doesn't like
to borrow money. So, they use a
debt ratio that's only, you know, 10
10.4%. They don't reinvest any very
much. Why? Cuz they didn't even think
there was a world that existed outside
the US. They were very US-centric. They
reinvested just enough to get So,
they're a low growth, low reinvestment,
low debt company. Value that I got
assuming the existing management
continued running was about $32 per
share.
But Hormel was being targeted by some
activist investors who wanted the
company to run differently.
By doing what? By being more aggressive
about the reinvestment. A 40%
reinvestment rate, which reduces cash
flows but increases growth,
and a slightly higher debt ratio. Debt
ratio of about 20%. So, I'm not going
crazy and putting them into leverage
buyout. So, slightly lower cost of
capital, slightly higher growth, the
value that I get is $38. I've got two
values. And this is similar to the
earlier the start of the class when
somebody to gave me two values for
corporate governance. I've two values
for this company.
Let's say its stock price is $32, $33,
$34. You're saying, "Which of these
two?" It depends on the likelihood of
change happening.
In the case of Hormel, I had one big
problem. The biggest shareholder in
Hormel was the Hormel Foundation.
The Hormel Foundation was actually the
family money that had been put into
foundation for tax purposes. It owned
like 30% of the shares in the company.
So, the Hormel Foundation voted for
change.
Change would probably happen. So, I went
and looked at who ran the Hormel
Foundation.
And I found that the Hormel CEO was the
chair of the Hormel Foundation. We have
a problem here, right?
He's not going to put pressure on
himself. So, the problem probability
that I attached to change was only 10%.
It's greater than zero because Hershey's
looked exactly the same way, and there
eventually the Hershey's board went for
change.
In the case of Hormel, I think the
probability is low. It's not zero. The
expected value then is the expected
value across those two.
I'm going to leave you with a with a
couple of final things because one of
the things I do in my corporate finance
class, and I haven't taught corporate
finance to undergraduates since 2015. I
think it was the last time I did it. In
my regular corporate finance class, I
talk about what happens to your cost of
capital as your debt ratio changes.
Contrary to the conventional wisdom,
increasing debt doesn't always lower
your cost of capital cuz when you change
your debt ratio, both your cost of
equity and the cost of debt go up. So,
in this case, turns out that the cost of
capital is actually minimized at about
20% to 30% debt. That's why I chose the
20 to 30%. I didn't arbitrarily pick it.
I looked to see where the cost of
capital would be minimized.
So, if you're working with mature
company, you have to ask a what if
question. Kind of ask the what if
question. Next session when we start,
we're going to talk about declining
companies and distressed companies. So,
if any of you pick one of those,
bring them in and we'll talk about what
to do with those companies. I'll see you
on Wednesday.
You're welcome. Take care.
Yeah.